welcome
fabio thank you
how are you doing thanks for coming on
the show
good shape to be hit
i've had a great time with fabio in the
no limit society he's been a
incredible agent
our god our dog barks in the background
is that your dog neighbors
there's both both
fabio is located in brazil he might be
the only
no limit society member in brazil
could ask some someone maybe probably
someone will enter
nls
because there was a brazilian in the
costa rica
retreat so maybe that person
can join as well
yeah raphael oh yeah
yeah that's right that's right so
technically there's a
for sure a confirmed second brazilian
fabios had this great presence in
nls where he carries both a
very relaxed and empty
vibe and then also a very
just authentic and unapologetic
mirroring reflecting direct pointing
and it's been really important
so i'm pumped
fabio will you tell us about your
experience with
awakening through the veilless veil
it started when i was 17
now i'm 35
but that moment i was
getting at my at the university
that i used to to work with work at
and i was walking
and suddenly i just
something shifted inside me like
i want to get better i don't know how
why just one two
and after that moment people
began to show up books
um this kind of things i was
looking for searching for
then suddenly friends that
were spiritual but i didn't know about
it
they
we began to to know each other
and then like the mother
one of them also was really into his
spirituality
she lent me books
to learn so i was eager to to read and
to understand and to
to get more knowledge i remember she was
the first that told me about the i am
but i didn't get it at the time at the
time
so i kept
looking studying more people showing up
then i went i met some people
they had meetings
where we there was a medium
he would channel these spirits
and i remember that
a few of them were already
pointing to the path i am right now
but i didn't get it at that time
and so this group went for
around seven years until this medium
passed away
um so this meeting was like a father to
me
it was really hard i entered
in uh around six months
really dark night
some suicidal thoughts
started coming
and i need to i was i could perceive
those thoughts it's
why i'm thinking about that
and then i just
decided to okay i don't want it i'm
going to change it somehow so
i began to search for things to increase
my energy
like
vegetarianism veganism
just searching also how to breathe
pranayama techniques
then i discovered about this britannian
process
or i had already i already knew this
process
um because a friend many years ago
um where they had taught me about it
then i
i began studying on saturday and about
this
return process and on wednesday i just
went for it okay i'll try one day and
let's see what happened
uh that night uh spirit came inside my
my bed like showing
encouraging me to just to follow this
this process next day
another two spirits okay
okay then i realized okay i'm going to
do it
so i did the process totally changed
my life because i it was a
process to deconstruct so many
thought patterns emotions
detoxify my body it was
amazing so
until it's been five years now
since this process and i still
follow this way to
balance my energy to to gain more
knowledge and consciousness about
how my body how this
patterns come so it's a
it's a tool to
to help me i don't people usually
think about it as oh if you do the
process you
you you should stop eating
you must never eat again but it's just
another
trick of the of your mind
so you need to release this resistance
as well this
belief that you should not eat
[Music]
well
and after that this process many other
things
many other tests open to me
like the presence benting masaru
and many others so i started to pursue
this emptiness
this awareness
and this is how i i can't
change this direction
i can maybe sometimes slow down but
always this direction i can
my final destination my final because we
don't have a destination but this is to
to realize you absolute i can't
shake it off
even sometimes comes some fear but
i face it until i overcome it
this is a short version of my
i love i love the mysterious
ways that source works with itself
because with its
creations it has this
playful way of revealing itself
to itself and so
you're just you know 17 just chilling in
your algorithms and then it's like
what the [ __ ] just changed like
wait what like there's something more to
this than the algorithms that i was just
than the script
and i love that and then sort of the
you know like okay well what is this
about like what is i who
am i what is reality what is
spirituality
and then the slowly over time like
wait that's what spirituality look at
all these people that are doing this and
that and the medium
the channeling all this type of stuff
to slowly guide you more and more
towards
what you're bathing in now with ventino
and
several others where you do feel the
very
i am-ness the very empty i
am-ness that is the eternal
awareness that's impersonal and that is
witnessing and playfully engaging in its
creations that are endless
and we are
that which makes even the
great i am
we are the very source of that as well
yeah it's interesting because from that
group
[Music]
maybe just one person
followed this began to to follow this
path
of presence and because i i
talk about it with him the first time i
i was explaining his presence his
emptiness
he was he thought that i was totally
crazy
but then uh new things
start to to show in his life
and he opened more to it and now he's
follow a little bit at least
from this presence
but the others they don't accept
really well imagine somebody walked up
to you when you were 17 and was just
like hey
have you ever thought about just being
he'd be like what are you talking about
like what do you mean
becoming aware of awareness or becoming
aware of the fact that i
exist well maybe
being i could acknowledge because
after the last years i could
remember many situations in my life
because well my life wasn't
really a paradise
and then you had the drill sergeant of
awakening
suffering come in there a bunch yeah
and during my
when i was teenager uh i remember
sometimes i'd like to to lay down
uh hammock and
just staring at the sky blue sky
and i completely forgot of everything it
was so light that moment
it was so every time after lunch
i would go there too to just relax and
how it's so good to be here in this
moment and it was because i was
obsessing just i was just being
it was the presence so it was so good
yeah and so even though we get these
little tastes or
glimpses of it it doesn't normalize
we don't really abide in it until we
really
taste at a more higher level what it
means to be
awakened to be truly conscious
of the fact that we exist
just really tapping in more and more
repeatedly to the very
awareness of awareness awareness of
being awareness
of i am i exist and you
like it like
we're so conditioned to not recognize it
and so even if we get this little
glimpse on the hammock
laying out that it ends up becoming more
and more of
wow it's like
beautiful water
it's like beautiful conversation with
fabio right now
and more and more beautiful my very
respiration itself
beautiful this very
flower shirt the peony
beautiful this very tennis ball that i
use
to stretch all of these
things that are we just algorithmically
move but
never to
i am god
i am the beautiful will
that is shared among us in lila
in the divine exploration of this
universe
i am the creator of this leela
just to and you see there's all these
little bit more macro level stages
because you can get to the i am
that i exist and you don't realize that
that's impersonal
among us all right so there's these
little
macro or like i created the universe for
this exploration but you can still you
could be stuck at the i am without
knowing that
it's funny because um
during this journey
i read many times ah you need to be
grateful
or the little things and i started to
to try it okay let's be grateful
but i would see things
but i couldn't really relate
because i was seeing it
with uh with the mind so it was
a heaviness
now i when i empty myself
just being it's like the other things
don't actually exist yes
yes it's all
a perception yeah
and then everything is is light
you know need to differentiate things
yes yes
and even words is so
limited you know
you try to use word to to point
something but it's not
really worth it you can't really
describe it
this is a lot easier the tennis ball
than
trying to describe what love
is yeah good luck using language for
that one
[Laughter]
yeah think about it from the dream
perspective
too when you dream you simulate
the observer in the reality where's the
separation
there is none also where is the
this is a tree and this is a house and
they're made of different things
nope just made of energy just like this
the very same no thingness
but i like to this year
i was with a group of friends and there
was a dog
and i was
seeing them and they're saying
how i love them and i was
okay what's
do i love them in different ways or
different amounts
so i was in my mind just put
everyone one side the other even the dog
in every single one of them
i would love the same way with the same
intensity
i couldn't differentiate uh
the only difference is that
the way i resonate with them like the
vibration like the
the symphony was the love was the same
for all
um that's another another way to put it
is that
you begin seeing everything as that same
god's love light leela
but then there are different resonances
which is why for example
you're wearing your green jacket
and why i'm wearing this peony shirt and
why i use this tennis ball on my wrist
and why you feel a different connection
to the light
that is your mother or your father then
you feel the different connection of
light
that is somebody on the street but you
still have the same
love light recognition for it
but why is it that there's such a
multi-year long
energetic resonance with your family
member
and so then there's that distinguishing
it's light in relationship to itself
so it's all light but different
relationship to itself
all energy different relationship to
itself
which is exactly how the creationary
play would go it goes from a zero
to a one the all-inclusive awareness
into a two plus
you get your two poles ascending and
playing together
and you get this refraction into
infinity
of all of the possibilities of colors of
expressions of forms
[Music]
just totally complete totally
always complete totally always free
totally always
creative totally always
aware and comprehending itself but it
requires one to fully recognize that
that is happening
in order for them to not be distracted
by the layers of
distortion so you don't know
it's comprehending itself but you don't
know because you're in the bubble
you're in the contracted energy state
it's comprehending the fact that you are
in your contracted state
but in order for you to know that you
are
it comprehending your contracted state
you have to turn
inward there's no other way to know the
data point
yeah the space is like
to get steeper
as you go i should deconstruct yourself
and sometimes you you think
you're not like progressing but
then suddenly you take a great step
big step
and then you can notice the difference
in a
more popular way
in the entire objective
of the creation is
to explore and play with itself
creatively anarchically
with a desire with an intention to see
what
unfolds that hasn't unfolded before
so you are literally being called
non-stop
to both go inward as the
gps callback to commune with the true
nature
and yet also to express yourself from
source outward as a firework that's why
you get the fabio and this gets the
atlas and that gets the paula and that
gets the karina
etc
and that's why one of you likes the
flower shirts the other one likes the
tennis balls the other one likes the
drawing
yeah each one with
their unique way of expressing and the
more you go within the more you stay
within
practicing writing your attention
inside
i'll see your expression of yourself
your individuality
comes like develops in a better way
you can express it more naturally
because
you're not blocking anything
you're clearing the way the path
[Music]
another way to say it is that you clean
out the channel
or the pipe the pipe itself
for the individuation to be in
pure service to the creation
rather than with the blockages in the
way
you're getting very little signal for
the love light
service to others rather you're getting
the
i'm the contracted form of energy
serving my
onion layer distortion of i need to
impress other
separate entities with my rolex
or whatever yeah yeah and then once you
realize it
absolute it's this pipe it just
ceases to exist so you
merge with everything you're nothing at
the same time
and the self-purification ends up
becoming more and more trusted
and less and less monitored
so right now i'm balancing between the
two but i'm experiencing a lot of
monitoring which has been really
important
for me when is it coming from source
when is it coming from conditioning
we talked about that a little bit on the
last call
yeah that was a good one
but a lot of people reject that process
and yeah and the re and usually the
reason why is because the
onion layer does not want to die yeah
yeah the first i think the last
fear that i had was six months ago i
think
and i was the fear was to forget my
passwords
and stuff like that
uh but i was
then i was watching some videos from
frank yang
and this fear totally
solved
and then no it's okay
now there are things that are subtle
i need to perceive and just to
pop the bubble of that perception
to make um
something without uh
bias yep
yeah that's a good way to put it yeah
is your firework coming from the person
consciousness
bias yeah yeah that's a great way to put
it
it's so good this
this journey because
first when you don't know about it
awareness you think i need to get better
i need to improve my
way to think of thinking how can i
get more
be a better professional like but as you
go within all these things
happen naturally
so you live better you
be more peaceful usually
once you clear the
the stuff you need to clear
but life
responds to you
you could even add the
it's a natural thing as you defocus or
empty that you not only get to this
being aware i am i exist
but you you notch back another
into the very source of the i am i exist
being aware so you get to this very
sense of voidness
nothingness allowing the clean pipeness
to come through into the i am
so you like you like emerge every
billionth of a second from nothingness
as an observer of the reality of your
own creation at play with itself and for
you to experience and watch it
and then every billionth of a second
just
just yeah
[Music]
just the absolute nothingness
comprehending
the absolute everythingness
yeah first you need to be a little bit
afraid because this all new sensations
and
this new kind of perception
but once you realize
how it so light to be present
to just be so
even if you have so many bad things
happening around you
you can seek refuge in this being
because you'll be peaceful
even around you is a hurricane
some say it's like
to be in the eye of a hurricane
hurricane i think but
or a twister maybe yeah say
it's peaceful yep yup hurricane or
tornado
regardless which which really is
once you get to that sort of stillness
imperturbable
peace it's so funny because you can like
all you have to do is click on the
mainstream news
and like you're just sitting there
abiding in peace
while the mainstream news is like
and you're just like oh my gosh there's
so little piece there it's crazy
i remember when once
you use to to see some to watch
sometimes in news
and things happening
sometimes i was just laughing about it
all the things that get
attention
people give importance to
things that don't really mean
to really why
i remember the phase last year where i
was
persistent about wanting to change those
that were addicted to propaganda
and so then you get liberated from the
need to
change that of yourself that is addicted
to propaganda
and you liberate yourself from the need
to change
your own body that's addicted to
propaganda
yeah and so that that's also another
step of liberation
from the bondage of needing to change
your creation
yeah so you hold simultaneously
having absolutely no desire with
also keeping in your north star position
igniting the
planetary enlightenment
yeah it's fun
like
[Music]
you begin to to be guided to
what you should do without thinking yep
you're empty and you just do things
you have more energy naturally
like yesterday i was uh testing
um to make a live in uh instagram
and i was just feeling how would be
because it would be my first life
by myself so
then celeria i clicked a button
expecting the the phone we would
do something different and the light
just began
okay and then i started to to speak
and many people like it and also
some uh said oh i
i dreamed about you three days ago
you were saying that i needed to you
needed to talk to me
and then you you put uh post this video
and it's helped me a lot
so things like that happen
a three minute video just what i needed
yep yep
i'm so glad you're getting the
experience of creating
conscious media it's so important
and you get the immediate reflection too
thank you
thank you this is that's great that's
great
i remember
after i read the book
the power of now was my introduction to
this
subject and i was
looking for teachers or people who i
could follow
and a friend
had told me about mooji
so the first contact was okay yeah
seems a nice guy but okay then a few
weeks later um that guy
okay i've tried i watched some more
videos and then i began to watch
many many videos just to to connect with
the energy
and the first realization i had was with
him
i was working on other cities so it was
[Music]
yeah and watching many videos during the
night
and suddenly something clicked
i did i began to smile so
wide and
tears was coming down a lot of tears
i couldn't it was so amazing so
light so
ah after that moment i need to
to stabilize to to be more with that
it's so great and then i couldn't
again perfect
that ineffable taste
of union is
what we seek that we already
are but we're not subtle enough to
detect it and then
after we unite with it because we
quieted our mind enough
to be able to detect that we are already
yet then we basically
re-baseline ourselves through this
perpetual realignment back to that state
of
perpetual union until it becomes home
yeah it's like we
we need to consciously look at it
yeah it begins yes yes
yeah yeah and and it's so important to
consciously keep looking keep looking
until
the first sort of pop happens and then
consciously keep looking keep looking at
what's the source what's the sort and
then pop and so
yeah i love that
yeah with time it gets more natural
like this weekend i had another shift
and now sorry tell us about it
yeah and
now it's like i can identify the things
like lose focus from my presence
my being but
uh when i come back
with attention awareness
it's more perceptible it's like
yep it's more it's more
firmly based maybe yep
and when i close my eyes or i just rest
it goes i sense it
much more deeper
uh it's like open new doors opened
like limiting limitations
um memories beliefs i can
now go easier it's easier to
to investigate this game this kind of
things
and yeah
it's it was a great shift
how's putting words
i like how you said the perceptibility
increases
that's a really good way to put it is
that
you sort of end up
becoming less and less
focused on the object and you become
more and more relaxed into the awareness
of the beingness itself
and then like if you learn how to just
sit down on the couch or out in the
sunlight and instead of like
having your mind run between thoughts if
you just like
realize like i'm
looking around as an observer right now
i am being presence awareness
right now i exist
and like if you look at things like when
you look at like a leaf
and then the leaf like blows along
the concrete on the ground and you're
just like why have i never seen a leaf
blow on the concrete before
and it and these are like the little
things that you actually have
never paid attention to because you're
not subtle enough
because you're too gross you're too much
in the physical
then you're not in the subtle formless
awareness that enables you to see these
novel new insights and so
then you become even more perceptible to
wow i actually make awareness i actually
make
realities and you become more and more
abiding
in this most voidness most emptiness
that gives rise
to infinite creation for you to
experience and witness
yeah like
one of my first experiences
with presents was something like that
2017 i was working
at a company and there are many there
were many
trees around the building
so i was walking in a break during a
break
and i was watching looking at these
trees
and i could perceive
when i was resting my attention
within i could
see the trees much more greener
wider and then i could perceive
exactly like suddenly the mind
came back and the my vision
shrinked yeah
and then i started to to practice this
okay
mine and presents they poop
yes
perfect
the color is it's different
once you get to that point of the
bifurcations
that's so profound where you can
actually be able to see the difference
between
when the mind contracts into a thought
like it races off you're experiencing
like this much more presence
being in this awareness openness you're
much more expansive you're actually
seeing new color in the tree you're
seeing the little squirrel jump around
from branches
you're like wow and then all of a sudden
your mind's like
don't forget about that phone call that
you have at 3 p.m are you ready for that
phone call
and it's like ah and then you just
breathe
and you let that thought disappear and
then you go okay back to this being
presents energy expansiveness and
like you become really good at the
deciphering yeah
at that moment sometimes was
some thought that could come
but i was trying i also
explained meant from experimenting
like sort of touches from the mind
like really subtle
into trajectories from the mind
so and just
that little thing could change my
perception
my of what i was seeing
mm-hmm yeah
just like the little bit of awareness
can subtly change the mind
as well yeah
yeah once you get
a view from
um once you get a view from the mind
from the awareness
you never come back yeah
you get a little glimpse of the
awareness and then you relax back into
that
and then if you get a little glimpse of
the mind while you're in awareness
you're like oh my gosh
that's what it was like yeah and you're
like
no way i'm not going back to that
yeah it's so robotic it's so
automatic yes
it's unconscious
one of ins
i remember once uh
a friend was murdered by her ex-friend
ex-husband
and she was living with my
grandma grandma that time
and i was
the first one to to know about it so i
went to the
to the place and was
like my presence
they turned on for two days
in a row i was always present because
if not i would i couldn't i wouldn't be
able to
to handle the all the energy around me
so heavy because of the family etc
then but there were two moments that
i could perceive my
my presence being just
a little bit out of alignment and i
could
sense all this pressure inside you know
from outside to me and well
so events like that can help you to
to keep in mind maintain your attention
on something
um so strong happen
yeah you can catalyst your
you to to reach a new high
your height yep and that's a key
insight is is am i a victim
to this suffering or am i the creator of
my own suffering catalysts
to awaken myself yeah such a simple
shift in perspective
it's simple now downstream to when
yeah but during
it just do your best to move your
attention into a more expanded
perspective rather than the contracted
perspective
like even yesterday it was so
interesting having
lost 10 minutes of a stream that i had
done
and immediately there was this feeling
of like
do i live in 2021 like what happened why
did i lose 10 minutes of this stream it
was such a profound bit
and then immediately right away i was
like i'm not a
victim to this i created this scenario
for myself
so that i could test my own ability to
maintain equanimous and peaceful
when this happened and then i just
literally watched my mind try
multiple times to be like oh you should
be angry right now you should be
frustrated and i'm like
nope good try i'm like nope i know
exactly where that goes
yeah yeah it can bother you sometimes or
maybe
many times depending
person or situation but
once you get rid of it not get rid but
you embrace it and integrate that thing
it won't bother you
again yes it was
there was a little bit something deep
down
yeah because you might still have a
little blind spot
and so yep and so it might come back to
be like hey
like did you check that little blind
spot and then
yeah so it's always in service to
awakening further yeah
actually i'd like to ask you about this
now how did you come
up with people experiencing
joy so we have
our calling here so so fabio is calling
us
my peop my calling is people
experiencing joy so
fabio where did joy sort of come during
the awakening process as something that
you adored enough to even
have as the north star calling
maybe maybe because the lack of joy in
my life
was so much time in stressful
environments created by my mind because
we create
things so and
i couldn't escape my mind i remember i
think
with four three years old i was already
just a busy mind with something talk
with the child
handle that yeah i
understood that i had him have us
[Music]
i'm really sensitive so
so i get thoughts from people around me
or
a group of people family and don't need
to be physical
near just energy energetically in
some way so this was
a great catalyst to
to propel me to
to search for peace and joy
so uh but these people experiencing joy
it came after a
nls no limit society called
but i could
get more here because i was just
checking and asking myself okay
what what do i
what is my calling what do i feel like
what would
be like if i'm
someone if i were to die like in a
minute
what would be my joy so first was
expressing sharing joy and how to be
because
i already knew that i want to share this
this presence this being
because just being i could
heal people yeah but i help
help people heal yes yes and not just
emotionally also
physically so
then i was
narrowing down the
and i came up with this people
experiencing joy
i think for the moments what resonates
the best with me
because just if i in a not a very good
mood
and or maybe tired
i just think about people experiencing
joy naturally
my heart expands and the smile comes
i love this one by holding the very
sourceful
energy we help people heal we help them
ascend we help them empty we help them
return to source and then to firework
from there it's
so good yeah
until last year i knew that i could help
people
just being present but i didn't know how
much
people would
get influenced by this peace
and to us a friend and okay
what's the difference uh your life with
fabian
without fabio and
she said phone
i can't explain you can't put in words
too much
just because i was she's a friend and i
was sharing these experiences
and this exercise that i was doing with
me okay let's try this
and just simple things and totally
transform
her life the way he
she use would deal with her family
friends child children
and you perform better like in your life
in general
like this is so
profoundly utilitarian even
like you just perform better
you perform with more happiness with
more peace
with more joy with more love with more
wisdom
wisdom yes
because mind can come okay how can i
handle that situation and
even if you just be suddenly you get
inspired
or just go for a walk and meet some
someone and that person can help you and
things
happen this way or even
through internet you can go online and
and find people you wouldn't imagine to
be friend with
i'm curious okay
when it comes to your calling being
people experiencing joy mind being
people experiencing truth
and many people's are people
experiencing some sort of profound
beautiful already here
state that we're just not subtle enough
to detect
so the question would be how do you feel
is an
optimal way for people to
undergo that very turned inward
towards the i am towards the being
towards the awareness
because that is towards the joy people
experiencing joy
joy is a natural byproduct of becoming
aware of awareness aware being aware of
i am so how do you in a sense
with your clients that you work with
with your friends that you help
how do you hit the hit the ball back
most commonly to people to just become
aware of
i am
defends the people some
who are really
um busy with their minds
with their ideas and i would suggest
just breathe like
it is uh just five seconds take a deep
breath
and exhale
just one breath you can
stop the the train of thought
was that was going so fast yes
if even if you do two three times
to really help you
and if you get used to it during the day
to do it like once every hour two
two times every one hour would be
perfect um other second guy item
uh like emoji he just
tell people to put their minds aside
just for a moment and so
let's keep questioning and asking them
to
to put their thoughts their memories
their family just for a moment
until we go to this i am
this presence and they can
if they go keep
moving aside everything that's the way
just relax until they find a place
they can describe they can
tell the if it's
big or not if it has color or not
you're in a place that you can use words
too
it's label
still the mind yeah
i i agree with you that's been the most
common
because you're right it totally depends
on the person and where they're at but
the most
common direct pointing is stop
for just two five seconds take a deep
breath
and just relax into the fact that you
exist and perpetuate
that process until your stop
the train of thought enough to where you
recognize your presence energy of just
being
itself and then recognize that
you are the source of being itself
and then over time you'll affiliate your
identity more
as the source of being and of creation
rather than i'm a contracted person
energy
in creation separate from all these
other contracted person
energies
the first i used muji many times to
lead it from him from him to so i could
get more and more of this
state spin
and connect this with this energy
there i was using the question
who am i yeah so i would
keep repeating who am i who am i who am
i who am i who am i
yeah yeah
like 20 20 30 40 times until i
i get this everything all depression
vanished
you know i can breathe
and it was funny because i was watching
all this content in english
and when i was trying to use the same
question in portuguese
it couldn't didn't work really well but
what
like how do you say who am i in
portuguese kingstowel
queso
yeah so what was the difference it's
just
it's the same meaning but just different
language okay
then i started to try i need to i had to
to repeat the question a few more times
maybe almost twice so they get the same
effect
but after that blockage
was overcome then i could didn't matter
now i could ask in english or portuguese
it's okay that's a really
interesting point to keep going though
keep going uh
yeah inventing you will introduce a new
question like
what is me he thinks is
translates better because it's not at
home
it's what is what is the absolute
yeah what is meat is a really good way
to put it
see if i can get this to
show up there it is
so yeah so we have kien soy
in spanish we have or
estoy that's what i was initially
thinking who am i
we have it's different okay
in spanish story and
it's like where am i
would be something like this and where
would be donde
donde estoy
a sense of place in soy
soy it's not in a sense of yeah
being okay so kian soy perfect so like
soy who am i or um kien
yo also like what
is me is another interesting one to put
it
key k s
yo right there's another one or
for russian it's toyah you know who am
i you know um and so this is really
interesting is that how many different
languages can you write out
who am i or what is me also
or as you know many other self-inquiry
rama maharshi and one now what is
i is another one right so what is me and
what is i are basically yeah
yeah i would definitely recommend people
of
in every single language to begin like
asking
the here i will we'll write them out for
people
okay who am i what is i
what is me and just put these in your
different languages let's see if we can
get a little space between these
my gosh these questions alone will
take you to your source
period there's these questions alone
will take you to your source
i think what is
who used this question for two years to
get
he realized himself man yeah siddhar
meshwar
told this you know i promise you you are
the absolute reality
just contemplate who am i what is i
what is me for two years and you'll
pierce this bayless veil
and so yeah we can we can definitely
bring the time
down for enlightenment or awakening
just based on this power law of like the
best
questions to ask oneself yeah so rather
than going into the
with a question of um oh how does the
neurobiology here produce sentience
which is you know go for it you can take
that approach if you want
but just go directly via the question
itself is
who am i what am i what is i
you know repeatedly and
yeah my who is perceiving
who is
because you can the form approach is
also useful but
that's a separate thing that's the
synthesis of science and spirituality
affinity and infinity
but you were saying who is perceiving
yeah um
like the idea is to go
how you can question to go deeper right
okay how can how you can overcome these
layers
pop the bubbles
and every time you have a better
perception
you are aware
and new questions will come
you start to perceive things
that before you couldn't
yeah these questions that fabio just
mentioned to who or what is looking
like this question will get you there
too
these questions will get you to becoming
aware of awareness aware of being aware
of yourself as the source of it
absolutely 100 these are the questions
i think that from where
is the one looking the one that is
looking
from where i is looking
you can't describe what you are you can
just
realize you can just
grow your awareness
of it so yeah
you can point it to people so so they
can
look there
[Music]
but they need to to see it for
themselves
i love it you can't describe it if you
want to you can call it
source i mean we don't really have
better words for it but yeah
ineffable the absolute whatever you want
to call it and then
um and then the best you can do is
like point people toward it which they
already
are but they just have to turn inward
it's like you have to
reverse everything like reverse creation
itself
back to witnessing and then reverse
witnessing itself
and um and then you're right it like
becomes a
like a deepening for over time it just
that that whole reversing process just
deepens over time
and then that's quote awakening or quote
enlightenment
is the process of both expanding
yourself to the whole universe being you
interacting with itself and the
dissolving of yourself into the very
nothingness which perceives the very
everythingness and it's the source of it
yeah you need to
to remove these layers this
this values one every time one
and i remember once
the first time i heard about you need to
go to look within do how
can i look with this
how can i perceive with him now i
understand okay perceive
i just move my attention to
to something within not really
my within my body but just
and with this intention you'll start to
to grasp it and okay and now i can
understand why it is within
but you just you just need to get to
give it time to
to get used to these terms these
pointings and
it will naturally come to you
that's a saint francis of assisi quote
that's another good one yeah
but you've really got to follow this
fabio
style approach what he's doing is what
the greats have done for
millennia and it's what i've learned
it's what
it's called the direct path or the
direct pointing
just go directly to the very source of
your perception
itself and become aware of
the fact that you generate and observe
the very creation and reality
and that you're the entire
thing you're not just a person
you're the whole thing playing with
itself endlessly
yeah but don't forget that
during this journey you need to
the things that are deep inside you need
to come up
so it can be anger it can be
any negative
emotion so it can you need to arise so
you can
perceive it and embrace it integrated
with it
so the mind will try to
to knock it out using this way
these these breeches
these blind spots so don't worry
yeah we'll definitely get a lot of
these
challenges which are our own catalyst
yeah but
once you've overcome it you'll get
you'll be much lighter sometimes you
need to
if you can stay with it like one two
days
to process some emotion some some energy
some bubble
once you pop it the difference
is noticeable it's
amazing you it's like you can
jump twice as high
before that because you
you have these uh
undulations oscillations so
when you go high in a vibration
all that is um
at the bottom won't can't keep up
so it needs to to go to the surface
then you go down there clean
integrate and then you start to go up
again
so this oscillation will will happen
many times
so don't worry the first
usually the first the first ones are the
bigger ones
so more fears things you can perceive
easier but then
the fears usually they
don't stick and then
uh this all these emotions the
sensations will get more
uh subtle setups so
yep the ascendant descent happening at
the same time is a really important part
of it as well
is that you're going to have these
periods of elation and unity and
nothingness and then it's going to be
followed by like having a
torches just
suffering and catalyst and that this is
gonna further
integrate and awaken you and
this is nice this is nice we got a lot
here fabio
we've got a lot here yeah we've got a
lot of good stuff
people experiencing joy
the very defocusing emptying into being
aware i
am i exist source void clean pipe being
your
way to get to that joy and peace that's
already present
in you asking the good questions who am
i what is i what is me
who is looking what is looking
from where is the one looking love these
yeah would you there has a saying
that um it's like
you're knocking the door open the door
open the door i want to go
to go inside but when the door opens
you realize that you were already inside
exactly
roomies quote yeah knocking on the door
from the inside
oh it's wrong okay yeah i heard from the
muji
yeah it's it's all the same sources
yeah yeah
thanks for coming on the show fabio yeah
thank you very much
i really enjoy it good
glad we've been
having a great time together in the fam
so this was
great timing to be able to express our
soul attunement together and how it
blossomed on the program and got to the
depths the joy and peace is
always there yet it remains for you
to recognize that
oh perfect
okay fabio where's the best place for
people to
[Music]
follow you instagram you said you had
some new video
content is that a good place yeah
let me write here oh
they know not valentina
potential create videos for youtube also
short videos um
sometimes it's portuguese but maybe i
i'll start to
put
forget the word subtitles
in english for people to enjoy
here or even recording some videos in
english
yeah it's a work in progress
so
i love this this is great
oh this white on white oh my gosh it's
hard to see
that's kind of cool though
i'm i'm testing things
so here's before i i decided to post
[Music]
i love it i love it so we'll put this
link in the bio
for everyone as well okay so go and give
fabio a nice little follow and check out
some of his great content there
and we would love to see some
english that'd be great too if you get
the chance because i know portuguese is
very important also
so whatever whatever you feel like is
most moving you
yeah i'm thinking how to maybe create a
an account in english
because i i wasn't expecting to
to talk too much in english but
people started to to happen
now uh ones that i'm
more interested in this in this subject
uh more and more written in english so
maybe i will
prioritize this language
i'll see you see we'll see yeah
i yeah i post something sometimes in
english and translating in portuguese
also so
yeah people can both
yeah people can enjoy yeah it'd be so
interesting every time you spoke to be
able to get it in mandarin
and arabic and spanish and english
right that'd be it'd be so great like
you know yeah yeah
speak judgment you can just
transmit our ideas and yeah
yeah yeah i remember murder said once
that
there was the mother of one of
the people who usually go to
the retreat and she didn't understand
english
but she kept watching
his videos and she didn't understand
words but she
understand the message she get the
energy
yeah this yep yeah
it does you just need to to open it and
not put a barrier because oh i don't
understand this language
if if you are open to the energy you can
get it
yeah i think rumi said we break all of
the layers until yeah
get to the heart yeah yeah
yeah and that's why with ramana maharshi
and whatnot darshan the direct
enlightenment communication can just be
done by that
presence no word
and that's why that example with muji as
well it's like
just the presence itself
sometimes you don't even need to get the
vocal vibration
yeah yeah there's this the ramana
aka enlightened who got enlightened
how did that happen how did that oh i
don't know i
just know that what happened i just know
that there was an enlightened cow
i don't know but like
during this past i can sense people
like when they are coming from mind
where they're coming from
their their source
their being yeah so it is easier to
understand
so probably as enlightened he can
he could cut it because it's just a
realization it's not
your capabilities it's not about your
skills and
stuff so you can get an environment
just be try the way you are with your
fears with your
habits all the stuff and
but once you realize that many things
will get cleared
automatically and others will
won't hold
yeah and eckhart tolle was saying that
his
zen masters were cats
yeah yeah so
beautiful
awesome fabio
thank you again thank you very much
that's amazing talk this is a really
good one
it's a really good one so excited thanks
everyone for tuning in
super appreciate you we would
love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below
if the video brought you value give it a
like subscribe if you haven't yet to the
channel and share the video with people
that you feel like
it would positively influence much
love thank you
bye bye everyone
you will stay in the studio we'll end
the broadcast all right